this month the next ps5 event is
reportedly happening but baldur's gate 3
is not and in september xbox game pass
xcloud support starts
this is my very official news notebook
i'm chastity and you've reached your
save save for tuesday august 4th
now plans could change but a new report
suggests that sony's next ps5 event is
coming later this month
bloomberg reports that the next ps5
stream is happening in august
the report reads quote an official at
the sony playstation unit who asked not
to be identified because the plan is not
yet public
said sony's next announcement regarding
the playstation 5 is tentatively
scheduled for this month
the last ps5 stream was in june when we
got a few game announcements like
spider-man miles morales and finally saw
what the console looks
like we still don't have a price or
release date so hopefully those details
will be part of the august event
but before that we're getting a 40
minute state of play focused on ps4 and
psvr games this thursday august 6th
at 1pm pacific and 4pm eastern and if
you can't watch sata play live we'll
bring you all the biggest news out of
that event on gamespot
one thing we know won't happen in august
is baldur's gate 3. early access has
been delayed so we'll just have to wait
for a new baldur's date the first act of
baldur's gate 3 was supposed to come to
early access in august but it's been
pushed back
larry in studio says the delay is due to
the challenging working conditions
during covid19
but we will be learning new details
about the game during the panel from
hell hosted by jeff keely on august 18th
at 10 a.m pacific 1 pm eastern we'll
learn the new early access launch date
then
the full game is planned for pc and
stadia and console versions aren't
confirmed but aren't entirely ruled out
either
and finally xcom give it to you in
september and by it of course i mean
xbox game pass xcloud support xcloud
support will be available for game pass
ultimate subscribers starting on
september 15th
ios support won't be available right at
launch but android will be
this is considered a beta launch and
will be available in 22
countries with more markets being added
over time this will let subscribers
stream their game pass library to their
mobile device and play the games
anywhere
there will be over 100 games available
at launch so far we know 30 of them
including halo the master chief
collection gears 5 and ori and the will
of the wisps
check out the full list of 30 on
gamespot to play you'll have to download
the gamepass
app and you can also play the games
using touch controls for example the
coalition designed a custom layout for
gears 5.
so you can play the games using xbox one
or even ps4 controllers but there are
also a range of new accessories from
third parties you can use
the 80 razer kishi splits apart like joy
cons and attaches to your device
power a and 8 bit d both have bluetooth
controllers with phone mounts
that's the news but while you're here
just a reminder that we're still raising
money for charity with the gamespot
store
you can get a face mask a t-shirt a
hoodie or a very rad skateboard
featuring an image of me about to eat an
entire rotisserie chicken
which is very accurate all proceeds go
to charity until the end of august so
head to the store get something cool and
help us raise money for a good cause
and that's your save save for tuesday
i'm chastity and you can find me on
twitter at chastity underscore v
and if you're looking for something to
watch check out our lists of what to
stream over on gamespot universe
take care and i'll see you next time
you